they vowed a return to the streets
following the sentencing of nine Catalan
politicians and activists for sedition
two weeks ago the tzunami Democratic a
leaderless anonymous organization called
on protesters to blockade Barcelona's
airport
one of the most defiant acts among days
of protests that occurred throughout
Catalonia the riots that came after that
which caused damage and disruption the
likes of which had not been seen in
decades Catalonia's usual peaceful
protest movement became drawn into a
controversy over the tactics used to
encourage civil disobedience and the
question was raised who or what is
tsunami democratic today in the Spanish
estate a Supreme Court ruling was
announced which is a direct affront to
the human rights the only person to be
associated with the movement so far
Manchester City's catalan manager Pep
Guardiola who has advocated for the
secession of catalonia his message for
Catalans to get behind the tzunami
democratic and it came out on the day
protesters occupied the airport the
reaction from the Spanish authorities
was swift a judge ordered their websites
and social media platforms to be shut
down part of ongoing investigation into
the movement the charges of terrorism
what we might assume perhaps is that the
same cattle and political parties which
were we had behind the 1st October
referendum and also the same
organizations are now behind this
anonymous platform but it it's some kind
of a political elite that has been
preparing this action for a lot of
months the domain of their website was
registered on july 2019 so we might
assume that they have been preparing
these for a lot of time so anyone who
wants to join the tzunami democratic
well they first have to download the app
on an android phone and then they have
to activate it by getting a QR code from
another user
now that code can only be used for a
limited amount of times now there's no
account as such that's created however
the user has to agree with the app being
able to track their location so far the
app is still awaiting activation but the
movement has already called for further
action before and after Spain's general
election next month in a bid to make
further waves in Catalonia Sonia gallo
al Jazeera Barcelona